hey youtubers is Charlie comic-con day
zero so I know everyone's bummed that
season seven has been delayed but we
actually just got like a new short winds
of winter excerpt and we learned where
they're gonna be filming season seven
which may include a tourney at Harrenhal
scene so careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on the show
so far so it's Wednesday it's Comic Con
day zero and we already have some news
about Game of Thrones Season seven they
just announced some of the cities that
it's gonna be filming and so based on
the look of where these places are I
mean obviously they're gonna be filming
later in the year so it'll be a little
more wintery a little colder but you get
a sense for where in Westeros they're
gonna be visiting and there was a new
brief winds of winter excerpt that
george RR martin revealed he posted a
picture of himself inside his office
working on winds of winter he had like
the manuscript up on his screen his
super old-school word processing program
now it was really far away like he
didn't intend to like release this but a
lot of people have deduced what it
actually says so I'll start with that
he appeared on John Oliver's last week
tonight this was taken from two weeks
ago and it seems like it's gonna be from
the Asha Greyjoy chapter now remember on
the TV show her name is Yara but she has
a chapter in winds of winter that
follows a Theon chapter so it just
appears like this is happening when she
is with Stannis now remember wins a
winner is very different from what
happened during Game of Thrones Season
six characters are alive that are dead
on the TV show Stannis is still alive
they're getting ready for the siege of
Winterfell like the big battle of the
bastards that they did on the TV show
Theon sister is a captive of Stannis so
she's reunited with Theon when he
arrives at Stannis's camp now remember
how Sansa and Theon fled Winterfell they
escaped Ramsay and made it to the wall
so in the books is just slightly
different instead of Sansa being at
Winterfell it's Jane Poole she's fake
Arya they're masquerading her as Arya
Stark Roose Bolton's like look I'm
marrying my son to a stark so the north
will support their claim so fake Arya
instead of sought sup because she and
Theon escaped they make their way to
Stannis's army and they're preparing to
lay siege to the Bolton army so because
this new little excerpt is taking place
in such close proximity to the Theon
chapter it just seems like it's taking
place after she and Theon are reunited
so when the book comes out you guys will
see it like the plot is very different
like the characters that are alive in
the books and on the TV show are in
different places just because like one
of the first really big departures from
the books was to put Sansa in Winterfell
on season five
so when winds of winter eventually does
come out which you know probably be
sometime early next year I'll do a
couple videos that will explain some of
like the major differences between the
books and the TV show but speaking of TV
shows season seven locations so a lot of
this is in Spain so it'll be very
beautiful even though they're waiting
til later in the year so that it's a
little more snowy one of the most
exciting new places is that they're
probably going to be doing Highgarden
like if you look at this castle here in
Almodovar Spain it looks like he could
double for Highgarden
obviously it's covered with a little bit
of snow so it remains to be seen how
forward in time we will be jumping so
even though Highgarden is really close
to dort like it would be really hot
there right now they might show it
snowing that far south by the end of the
season but in order to do that they
would have to jump way forward in time
Daenerys is sailing with her fleet so
naturally there's a lot of seaside
locations if you look here there's this
location near berm a oh this looks like
it could be iron islands they could even
do Dragonstone I know a lot of people
are wondering if the nurse is gonna go
back to Dragonstone that's actually
where she was born
but Dragonstone as Stannis says has
obsidian all over it in season five when
he was at the wall they were talking
about dragonglass scene he was like I
know what that is it's all over
Dragonstone so a little bomb goes off in
your brain and you just kind of file
that away for later like hmm that's
gonna come in handy in a couple seasons
and I know we've been hyping tourney at
Harrenhal but there's this location here
near the ruins of Italica that look very
much like the dragon pit of murine this
could totally double for a tourney at
Harrenhal location otherwise you wonder
what they would be using it for if not a
tournament I mean naturally you would
think that this belongs in Essos but it
doesn't seem like we're gonna be
spending a lot of time in the east next
season because all the main characters
have really come back to Westeros so
unless Daenerys is going to be holding a
tournament in modern-day in Dorne it
looks like this might be for flashback
turning Harrenhal purposes but you guys
can let me know like do you think that
if they film in a Coliseum
I mean imagine it's done up with CG and
there's people all over it but what
possible reason in present-day could
they have to film a tournament like
Cersei isn't a big fan of tourney's
she's probably not gonna start throwing
tourney's all the time now that she just
blew up the great Sept but fingers
crossed for tourney at Harrenhal
as for the Iceland scene so they're
gonna be filming in Iceland in January
so it's gonna be super cold it's gonna
look like it would normally look north
of the wall
so I'm guessing all the Iceland stuff
will be the stuff that's happening in
and around the wall that's not directly
at Castle black so if you didn't know
the Castle black set like when they're
filming scenes at Castle black that's in
Northern Ireland so they have like a
small portion of the wall that's built
there but as I said like the really big
new things that they'll be filming will
be Daenerys during the seaside locations
like her big fleet sailing up the coast
hi garden more flashbacks you know
tourney and Harrenhal fingers crossed
that's unconfirmed but they just seems
like the best option if they're not
gonna be using that in a present-day
scene and then just a vastly different
landscape for the north and you've seen
before like the north is still
relatively green and obviously they're
still filming in a lot of different
locations in Spain so that's well
they'll be filming there King's Landing
scenes so as is the case with past
seasons like when you move into a new
season they show a couple big new places
that we haven't been to yet in Westeros
in return to the really important places
where the main characters are King's
Landing is always going to be a big deal
even though the battle for the Iron
Throne isn't as big a thing as it used
to be it is still very much a big thing
even in like the final season when
Daenerys probably realizes the threat of
the White Walkers and all the focus
turns to what's happening in the north
Littlefinger will still be trying to
scheme and plot his way to the Iron
Throne if he survives which I think that
he will he's like the bacteria on the
underside of your shoot like he'll find
a way to survive he would survive a
nuclear holocaust like a cockroach so
again I Game of Thrones Comic Con panel
is this Friday so I'll post a video for
that after that post there is a new
round of the giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video
they'll be giveaways for like the Marvel
the DC stuff I'm doing so just look at
when I post videos for each of those and
I will be live-tweeting Comic Con
posting on Facebook so here are the
links for that if you guys didn't know
it's gonna be an awesome week there's
gonna be a whole bunch of stuff I'll try
to do as many videos as possible but
I'll probably be limited to like two you
know maybe three videos a day depending
on what happens while you guys wait for
the next one to post you can click here
for like my master Comic Con playlist
and you can click here to learn all
about what the actress who plays lyanna
stark's said about her big jon snow
flashback thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you